hello everyone and welcome to the round
two of this year's classical super
tournament to the superbit chess classic
we have a great game between the Local
Hero booked and Daniel Dak and Jani
ponishi who just finished his world
Choice championship match against
England and if you guys remember what
Fabiana corvana said as he was also
commenting on the worldshire
championship match he said that after
his game against Magnus Carlsen in 2018
in London uh after his match at the
world to championship match he he had
leftover preparation for uh at least one
incredible tournament and then maybe a
little bit of preparation for one more
tournament and then maybe here and there
you know you you remember something that
you had prepared and you you're able to
uh you know launch an attack or defend a
a a a difficult position or something uh
but you think yeah okay you think that
maybe you have like for for a full year
of tournaments no Fabi says that you
have like for one Goods tournament this
is the first tournament nipple is
playing after the World Chess
Championship match so let's see what he
has prepared and are there any good
leftovers so Bogdan Daniel has the white
pieces and he opens with Pont uh Ponte
D4 as you can see uh he's 2700 uh sorry
about that
uh he's 2700 and nepo is very very close
to 2800 both him and England are very
close to 2800 so if they do well here in
this tournament they could break the
2800 barrier so here we have ponted the
fortnite to F6 uh C4 E6 Knight to F3 and
now Pawn to D5 going for the Queen's
Gambit declined Knight to C3 Bishop to
E7 and now Bishop to F4 uh the the
harvest attack we have castles uh Ponto
E3 and C5 so this is all a very very
standard stuff this this is the absolute
main line so they are not doing any
uh Adventure seeking here so the
captures and c5b Bishop captures and
pawn to A3 preparing some B4 in the
future uh Knights the C6 and now Queen
to CQ we have Queen to A5 uh sort of
going into that B4 move but you can't
really because uh well uh Bishop can
just capture and the rook and A1 is
undefended so here Rook the D1 and now
uh usually in this position it's a very
well known position people just move
back the bishop Bishop to E7 and there
are some other lines like Rook to E8
Rook the d8
um also a well-known move uh I'm sure
you guys have seen it but here nepo
plays Ponte H6 and it is not a new move
it has been played a few times by uh
some uh some uh interesting players like
Laura Laura and fresenay tried it uh
Casa Coley tried it and uh well it's
very very complicated the point is if
you strike with B4 right away uh black
gets an incredible attack look at this
Knight captures and B4 a characters
Bishop captures how do you how to save
the Knight you can play some like Bishop
to E5 but it then comes Knight to E4
just uh piling up on the Knight on C3
and after Rook C1 now you chase away the
bishop and that's it white can pretty
much resign so instead after this uh H6
move uh we have Bishop to E2 by Bogota
Daniel and now Knights the E4 nipple
just uh piles up on the C3 Knight C
captures on D5 and now there is a game
where Knight captures and C3 was played
but here we have ecat person D5 and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and this is what
nepo had in mind look at this Rook
captures on D5 uh sort of uh pins the
bishop to the queen but now comes Knight
captures and C3 Queen captures and
nipple just plays Bishop to B4 look at
this uh spectacular idea now the point
is if you capture the queen then nipple
will first capture the queen with check
and after you capture also gobble up the
rook and A5 he's gonna be up the
exchange and he's gonna enjoy his
position very much the A and three the
NC Pawn a week is going to be able to
gobble them up and very likely win the
game easily so Bogota Daniel tries a
different approach he tries eight
characters on B4 also gives up the
exchange but you don't really have any
other choice here Queen capture Sun D5
and now Pawn to B5 attacking the Knight
Knight's day seven and he just castles
to safety and now if you look at this
position uh yes nipple is on the
exchange but uh bogdon Daniel is up a
pawn and his B5 Pawn although it's a
double Pawn uh prevents Nepal from just
advancing those uh those pawns to
Victory so here we have Bishop to E6 uh
and now comes Knight to D4 going after
the bishop here uh we have uh Knight to
F5 offering a trade of knights and now
just a trade on E6 Knight for Bishop
captures captures and pawn to H3 we have
Rook F to d8 and now Bishop to F3 uh
look at that Bishop pair doing a very
good job here and it seems like it's
very hard for nepot to get the Rook into
the game but there is a rook to C8 Rook
8 the C8 just attacks the queen so Queen
to A5 and now how do you defend the
pawns well you don't Nepal just play
spawn to B6 he will uh use his B Pawn to
stop the the the Double B Pawn uh and
after Queen captures an A7 now he shifts
the attention over to the king Side Pawn
to G5 and now he says yes you do have
The Bishop's pair uh but uh your your
two to one advantage on the queen side
doesn't really do anything as those
pawns are completely blockaded the
Bishops aren't really targeting anything
there's nothing there to Target those
Bishops are are not very nicely placed
uh and also maybe the king safety will
be an issue here so how are you
defending we have Bishop to H2 Knight to
H4 now nipple goes after the bishop here
Bishop to B7 and now Rook the C2 now
nipple will bring the other Rook to D2
and go for a very nice King side attack
we have Queen the A4 attacks The Rook
but just Rook to C4 attacks the queen
right back Queen back to A6 and now King
to G7 a little bit of King City uh
before deciding on how to continue with
the attack and now Pawn to B4 uh this
opens up this diagonal while also sorry
not that obviously uh this diagonal wall
also prevents Rook captures on B4 if you
if you play that
uh then you lose control over the C7
Square Bishop C7 will Target The Rook
end to the pawn here so it may be giving
your opponent a bit too much so Rook to
C2 by nepo Queen to A1 with check and
not even Pawn to F6 we have King to H1
uh but now you lose control over the F2
Pawn so nepo brings the other Rook into
the attack Rook D to D2 with Tempo
attacking the F2 Pawn so Bishop G3
attacks the Knight Knights the F5 goes
after the bishop we have Bishop to C6
now uh and Rook to A2 and here uh both
uh sorry Rook day two attacks the queen
queen to B1 and now Ponta H5 uh you
could also start some Pawn grabbing or
you could mess up white spawn structure
but nepo wants the further push pawns
and go for the attack so Queen to E4 you
have to trade Queens otherwise uh well
you you're just gonna get crushed uh
Queen capture Sunny for Bishop captures
and now nipple trades Knight captures
and G3 F caption G3 and now Rook 8 and
B2 and now you can see that this Pawn
will definitely fall it's on a dark
Square this spawn will very likely Fall
as it's on a dark square and Only The
Rook can defend it so is there any
counter play here is it is it possible
to save this position uh the answer is
no so here we have Bishop to F3 uh King
to H6 and now Pawn to G for nipple of
course keeps the position blocked he
wants the pawns on the same squares as
the slide Square Bishop so they're not
really very useful Bishop to C6 and now
just Kink the G7 hippo will win the B4
Pawn at some point uh he just doesn't
need to rush it King to H2 now comes
with Rook captures and be formed as
there is really no uh better way to
improve for the moment and now Rook the
A1 uh here you might be thinking but
what about Rook D1 can't we just defend
the pawn with the rook and keep this
Pawn Defender with the bishop yes you
can but Rook B to B2 and the white is
out of moves and you know that in a
position where you're out of moves
you're in a tube swung at some point you
will have to make a terrible move
uh that that will cost you the game you
will not be able to keep defending this
Pawn at this pawn and this pawn and also
stop uh all the counter play from black
so uh usually players um when they have
to decide whether to go into such a
passive position and wait for a strong
almost 2800 Grand Master like nipple to
just uh show his Mastery and crush them
they will uh seek for activity at the
price of material so here Rook the A1
was played Rook to E2 nipple goes after
the pawn now King G1 we have Rook B to
B2 uh Rook to A7 with check with King to
f8 now comes Rook to A8 with the check
King to E7 and he was in this position
on move 44 that Boggs and Daniel Dak
resigned to the game and a very nice
victory for for Yani polishi in round
two of this year's Super bet chess
classic and now this is a you know it's
it's not a complicated end game but I'm
sure some of you are wondering how do
you how do you win this how do you
because the bishop is guarding this pawn
and also this Pawn so uh surely uh you
you get the idea you will course uh a
white to trade one rook and then at some
point at the perfect moment you will
bring your king to C5 or or maybe to D6
and you will try to give up this the
other Rook for the bishop to win the
bishop and the pawn so if you guys are
interested how the game might be
concluded let's say Rook A7 you give
some checks Rook day one uh let's say
you harass The Rook a little bit you
will capture the E3 Pawn there was uh no
stopping that let's say Rook to F1 and
okay it seems that white is just
shuffling the Rogue back and forth but
now Rook e to E2 Rook to B1 you still
wait Rook to E5 now and now after the
king moves you will double up on the E
file and now the problem is uh like I
said you can't defend everything now you
win the back rank first you play after
something Rook to E1 now you force The
Rook off of the back rank or white
straight and then we continue with our
plan of bringing the king to C5 and just
picking up the pawn on B5 so here white
will have to move the Rook from the back
Rank and now you set up uh both of the
Rooks on the on the back rank you will
play Rook D1 and now white will be
without a choice he will have to trade
Rooks uh yeah otherwise he's just gonna
get checkmated uh let's say captures
captures and now we proceed with the
plan of just winning this spawn whatever
you play King is coming to C5 and after
the bishop moves you will happily
capture this pawn and now either you
move the rook and start advancing the
pawn or white trades and now of course
you are completely winning you just move
the king and Advance your past V Pawn to
Victory as one most often does
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by nepo
already after he captures on D5 a
completely new position and then this
beautiful uh Bishop to B4 move uh I
don't know if I mean surely it's not
something spectacular that would work
well in world's championship match but
if we if there was a classical Queen's
Gambit declined uh you know with all the
main lines so then we we might see this
and uh you know it could be a very
interesting uh approach to see how ding
would handle such a position but okay uh
here he he was able to probably use some
of his uh World Series Championship
preparation so we'll see how long that
will last him as Fabi say maybe maybe
one tournament but maybe maybe even more
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very very nicely done by nepo
uh I would like to thank Mark burzakaki
uh Keith tester Edmond Freeman Evan
Bursey and Madison El sarag for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful classical tournament until it
finishes uh let's see if anyone can
break 2 800 here or will someone else be
the hero of the show uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of you